tant au château de versailles on ne peut
visiter actuellement que 15 cents mètres
carrés plutôt frustrant pour un château
qui renferme plusieurs milliers
d'oeuvres d'art frustration peut être
oublié bientôt avec la réouverture
annoncée si le mystère de la culture
arrive à recruter les gardiens
nécessaire du musée de l'histoire de
france créée par louis philippe et qui
avait été fermé après la première guerre
mondiale
pour combler votre légitime impatience
visite guidée en compagnie de gérard
dalmas et daniel lefebvre la maison du
roi soleil va ouvrir en cinq ans le plus
grand livre d'histoire en images du
monde et musiques de toutes les douars
de la france six mille tableaux par des
lustres pointures de la peinture du
xviie à 1919 125 salle en état d'être
exploités d'hommes battant en visite
libre et non plus seulement un groupe
conférence
pourtant la sphère n'est pas ça problème
de personnel à engager 200 gardiens donc
à blesle de gros sous il nous faudrait
pratiquement de l'ordre de 200 gardes de
200 agents en a une cinquantaine
donc c'est au fur et à mesure de
l'arrivée de ces personnels conduira sur
deux trois quatre cinq ans ça ça dépend
de décisions de 2007 la culture et du
ministère des finances
qui plus est la politique de masse
triche mais un coup de frein à
l'engagement des employés de l'état
heureusement le nouveau patron de
versailles est épaulé dans sa démarche
par le président de la société des amis
de versailles comme hubert astier
olivier de rohan tient beaucoup à la
réouverture totale du musée de
l'histoire de france
quinze mille mètres carrés qui
s'ajouteront par étape aux quinze mille
mètres carrés actuellement en visite
libre mais tellement fréquentes et qu'on
se croirait parfois dans le métro aux
heures de pointe un nouveau souffle
bienvenue au château magique autres
soirs nous c'est d'en faire profiter le
maximum de gens nous voulons souhaitons
qu'il ya plus de gens qui connaissent
versailles qui est plus de gens qui en
profitent et nous ne nous essayons nous
organiser pour le leur permettre de
connaître mais versailles et d'avoir des
moyens d'y accéder plus facilement et de
pouvoir s'instruire appart de tout ce
qu'ils disent 837 oui philippe a le
mérite
l'opiniâtreté le culot de constituer
cette fabuleuse collection commandes
réserve royal impériale saisi
révolutionnaire le roi citoyen joue sur
tous les tableaux
même quand le sublime n'est encore
qu'une esquisse le serment du jeu de
paume
david
le musée de l'histoire de france victor
hugo l'affirmé est un livre magnifique
dont la magnifique reliure s'appelle le
ver salle